We've got an incredible woman to tell you about.
"The Washington Post" reports that a teacher in Virginia
named Jennifer Williams has made it her personal mission
to give away one million books to kids for free.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
A million books?
The book lady
has already given away 90,500 books,
spending tens of thousands of dollars of her own money.
And she teaches fifth grade
and tutors on the side to make it all happen.
She brings books to students at schools,
and stocks local libraries,
and builds boxes and those little like house things.
I love those.
I have one of those in my neighborhood.
Take a book, leave a book?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
There's one right there.
Uh-huh, mm-hmm.
And Jennifer says, "Having books at home
can make all the difference in developing vocabulary
and communication skills."
And I will say, Jennifer, that I am completely self-taught
and it is totally from books.
So I commend you. I thank you.
And keep up the good work!
(audience applauds)
Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
Yes, yes.
Amazing.
Well, next up, we've got some good news
for the old taste buds.
It's "Food News!"
Oh, nom nom nom.
Nom nom nom.
Oh, that's Sammy Sullivan
(audience cheers)
doing the nom nom noms.
What is this now?
So the world's ice cream scientists have done it again.
And this time, they've turned churros into ice cream.
Raise some hands, who likes churros?
Oh, oh.
What is it about out those delightful ropes
of sugar and carbs?
It's my kryptonite.
Sugar, I will do anything for a churro.
Do you understand?
(audience laughs)
Well, Dulce de Leche Churro
is the latest flavor from Haagen-Dazs.
And I just had to try it and let everybody know
about this new concoction that's available.
Okay, let's do.
Mm-mm.
(audience laughs)
God.
That good.
Oh.
(spoon clatters)
(audience applauds)
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Okay, it tastes so specifically something
and I'm wondering-
Churros!
(audience laughs)
It's a churro,
but it's the Cinnamon Toast Crunch of it all.
You know what I mean?
It's like in the bottom of the bowl
with the milk and the yum and the mm-hmm.
I mean, I really, just little recommendation,
go pick yourself a pint of Dulce de Leche Churro.
Two pints, all right?
Yeah, absolutely.
We're the taste testers,
and I think we give it a five-star review.
Can I give it 10?
Yes, we'll be.
(audience applauds)
Coming up, we've got an incredible woman to tell you about.
"The Washington Post reports that a teacher in Virginia
named Jennifer Williams has made it her personal mission
to give away one million books to kids for free.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
A million books?
The book lady
has already given away 90,500 books,
spending tens of thousands of dollars of her own money.
And she teaches fifth grade
and tutors on the side to make it all happen.
She brings books to students at schools,
and stocks local libraries,
and builds boxes and those little like house things.
I love those.
I have one of those in my neighborhood.
Take a book, leave a book?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
There's one right there.
Uh-huh, mm-hmm.
And Jennifer says, "Having books at home
can make all the difference in developing vocabulary
and communication skills."
And I will say, Jennifer, that I am completely self-taught
and it is totally from books.
So I commend you. I thank you.
And keep up the good work!
(audience applauds)
Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
Yes, yes.
Amazing.
Well, next up, we've got some good news
for the old taste buds.
It's "Food News!"
Oh, nom nom nom.
Nom nom nom.
Oh, that's Sammy Sullivan doing the nom nom noms.
What is this now?
So the world's ice cream scientists have done it again.
And this time, they've turned churros into ice cream.
Raise some hands, who likes churros?
Oh, oh.
What is it about those delightful ropes
of sugar and carbs?
It's my kryptonite.
Sugar, I will do anything for a churro.
Do you understand?
(audience laughs)
Well, Dulce de Leche Churro
is the latest flavor from Haagen-Dazs.
And I just had to try it and let everybody know
about this new concoction that's available.
Okay, let's do, mm-mm.
(audience laughs)
God.
That good.
Oh.
(spoon clatters)
(audience applauds)
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Okay, it tastes so specifically something and I'm wondering-
Churros!
(audience laughs)
It's a churro,
but it's the Cinnamon Toast Crunch of it all.
You know what I mean?
It's like in the bottom of the bowl
with the milk and the yum and the mm-hmm.
I mean, I really, just little recommendation,
go pick yourself a pint of Dulce de Leche Churro.
Two pints, all right?
Yeah, absolutely.
We're the taste testers,
and I think we give it a five-star review.
Can I give it 10?
(upbeat pop music)